frédéric viale auteur et spécialiste des
questions européennes
frédéric viale bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nos siorat rt france
alors emmanuel macron qui demande à
londres de choisir quelle relation elle
souhaite avoir avec l'union européenne
ce choix n'at-il pas été déjà fait lors
de la négociation de l'accord poster
excite
oui vous avez absolument raison ce choix
il a été fait et effectivement il y à un
accord là qui a été qui a été signé et
qui au fond est très proche de ce que je
voulais la grande bretagne
c'est à dire que la grande bretagne a
obtenu tout ce qu elle tout ce qu'elle
souhaitait c'est assez normal d'ailleurs
parce que au fond l'union européenne n'a
pas véritablement de projets en dehors
de l'application des règles de la
concurrence et de la libre circulation
des capitaux
la grande bretagne voulait ça aussi elle
a obtenu est donc pour reprendre la
petite citation de macron qui dit la
grande bretagne doit choisir elle ne
peut pas être en même temps le meilleur
allié des états unis le meilleur ami
l'union européenne et singapour
et bien malheureusement on aura les
trois c'est à dire que la grande
bretagne va poursuivre sa politique qui
consiste à être la tête de pont des
états unis près l'union européenne et le
paradis fiscal qu'elle n'a jamais cessé
d'être
y compris quand elle était membre
d'union européenne de quelle marge de
manoeuvre dispose le gouvernement
britannique dans l'accord il est tout à
fait il est tout à fait important c'est
à dire que il a obtenu finalement le
gouvernement britannique qu'il y ait un
accès aux marchés de l'union européenne
d'une part et par ailleurs n'y a pas de
restriction sur le mouvement des
capitaux
bon donc à partir de là les politiques
néolibérales à ces forcenés que veut
mener la grande bretagne vont se
poursuivre la grande bretagne est un
paradis fiscal et va continuer d'être un
paradis fiscal donc on a effectivement
consenti l'union européenne a consenti à
ce que à sa porte
soit mis en place un petit singapour
voilà ce qui va se passer et de ce point
de vue la grande bretagne au plus ce
qu'elle voulait le royaume uni se dit
tout de même prêt à changer
sa façon de faire et ses directives
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne qu'est
ce que cela pourrait signifier
concrètement concrètement pas grand
chose on est vraiment dans des prises de
position des uns et des autres qui
relève de la diplomatie évidemment le
premier ministre britannique n'est pas
un imbécile et il sait tenir les
discours qu'il faut tenir au moment
opportun
voyez jouer emmanuel macron qui se veut
le défenseur acharné d'une union
européenne qui par ailleurs n'a pas
réellement de projets se trouvent amené
à faire un peu des rodomontades comme ça
des moulinets verbaux et en face le
premier ministre britannique ça lui
coûte véritablement pas le cheikh de
dire mais oui on va changer d'attitude
on va être compréhensif vis-à-vis de
vous mais sur la réalité des relations
elles sont encadrées par cet accord
j ai un accord plutôt favorable à la
grande bretagne qui est un accord qui
par ailleurs lui va lui permettre de
poursuivre les politiques qu'elle avait
de toute façon décidé pour suivre donc
voilà tout ça tout ça c'est beaucoup de
communication
est ce que d'autres pays pourraient
suivre l'exemple de la france est est
monté au créneau selon vous ben c'est
toujours pareil montroc monter au
créneau sur quoi si on est dans la
volonté d'une application stricte de
l'accord de l'accord entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne
oui bon pourquoi pas mais et alors la
grande-bretagne l'allemagne la france
tous ces gens fille de faim tous ces
gens tous ces gouvernements ont au fond
un objectif commun qui est de poursuivre
le business comme avant c'est ce qui va
se passer tranquillement pour revenir à
la déclaration des manuels match mais il
a quand même eu des mots assez fort il a
déclaré que cette sortie de lieux était
selon lui une erreur au crédit quand
même les mensonges qui ont pu mener à ce
résultat les les relations de la france
et du royaume uni peuvent sur le long
terme être se dégrade et que le
président emmanuel macron considère que
les britanniques ont fait une erreur ça
n'a strictement aucune importance je dis
bien
tristement aucune importance les
britanniques se sont prononcés ils ont
voté c'est la règle de la démocratie on
sait que le président macro n'aime pas
la démocratie
on y vient de le dire encore une fois ça
n'a strictement aucune importance
maintenant les dégradations
diplomatiques avec la france
encore une fois ça va dépendre de ce que
la france veut réellement
est ce que la france entend lutter
contre la grande bretagne comme paradis
fiscal
alors si c'est le cas oui inévitablement
les relations vont ces gradés mais ce
n'est pas le cas c'est à dire que
emmanuel macron n'a strictement pour
l'instant en tous les cas aucune espèce
de début de commencement de volonté de
lutter contre le sel que la grande
bretagne soit un paradis fiscal
si strictement aucune merci beaucoup en
tout cas frédéric viale avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes auteur et spécialiste des
questions européennes